양자 컴퓨팅 실전 강의에 다시 오신 걸 환영해요. 이번 에피소드는 첫 번째이자 종종 가장
어려운 단계인 양자 프로그램 정의에 집중할 거예요. 일반적인 문제를 양자
컴퓨터에서 실행할 수 있는 circuit으로 매핑하는 거죠. 이 단계는 주어진 계산
문제에서 시작한 사용자가 양자 컴퓨터가 이해할 수 있도록 변환하는 방법을 설명해요.
이 시리즈의 이전 강의, 2강과 3강에서 매핑 단계가 Qiskit patterns 프레임워크의 첫 번째 단계라고 설명했어요.
그 강의들에서 우리의 목표가 계산 문제를 비용 함수나 기댓값으로 변환하거나
다시 쓰는 것이었다는 게 기억나실 거예요.
그 기댓값을 양자 컴퓨터로 평가할 수 있는 거죠.
3강에서는 max cut이라는 구체적인 예시를 다뤘는데,
계산적으로 어렵고 조합 최적화에서 흔히 볼 수 있는 문제예요.
그 예시에서 초기 그래프를 양자 고유 문제로 변환하는 여러 단계를 거쳤어요.
그래프에서 최대 컷 수를 찾는 문제를 비용 함수로 변환하고, 그 비용 함수를
Hamiltonian으로 다시 썼으며, 기저 상태가
max cut에 해당하는 시험 양자 상태를 준비했어요. 마지막으로 원하는 시험 양자 상태를 나타내는 quantum circuit을 구성하고
상태가 시간에 따라 진화하도록 특정 gate들을 추가했어요. 이 일련의 단계들이 우리가
매핑이라고 부르는 거예요. 큰 그림에서 보면 이 절차는 양자 화학 같은 많은 다른 응용 분야에도
일반적으로 적용돼요. 양자 시뮬레이션도 마찬가지고요. 자, 매핑이 어려울 수 있다는 사실을 외면할 수는 없어요.
모든 단일 문제에 맞는 만능 전략은 없기 때문에 막막할 수 있어요. 오늘은
여러 문제의 대표적인 예시들을 소개하고 각 경우에 어떻게 매핑했는지 설명할 거예요.
Max Cut에서 사용된 것 같은 그래프 문제에 대해 배운 내용을 빠르게 정리하고 나머지 강의는
자연에서 나타나는 문제들, 예를 들면 생물학의 분자 구조 문제, 전자
화학의 구조 문제, 고에너지 물리학의 양자 장론 시뮬레이션에 집중할 거예요.
하지만 이 에피소드의 대부분을 문헌 속 예제 문제들을 살펴보는 데 쓰기 전에, 문제를 매핑할 때
우리가 달성하고 고려하고 싶은 주요 사항들을 큰 그림에서 먼저 보여드리고 싶어요.
quantum circuit으로 변환해야 하는 어떤 유형의 계산 문제에 대해서도 고려해야 할 몇 가지 사항이 있어요.
첫째, 문제를 실행 가능하게 만들기 위해 단순화해야 할 수도 있어요. 이건 대부분의 과학
분야에서 흔한 일이에요. 양자 컴퓨팅에만 국한된 게 아니에요. "구형 소를 가정하라"는
표현을 들어보셨다면, 시스템을 있는 그대로 정확하게 묘사하기 어렵다는 사실을 암시하는 거예요.
대신, 여전히 유용한 해결책으로 이어질 수 있는 합리적인 단순화를 할 수 있어요.
양자 컴퓨팅에서 이렇게 할 수 있는 몇 가지 예시로는 hardware efficient ansatz를 선택하거나 복잡한 시간 진화를 잘라내서 circuit의 크기나 깊이를 제한하거나,
또는 양자 상태의 최종 에너지에 거의 기여하지 않는 Hamiltonian 항들을
무시하는 방법들이 있어요.
다음으로 말씀드리고 싶은 건, 양자 컴퓨터가 이해할 수 있는 방식으로 문제를 작성하는 것에 대해 생각해야 한다는 거예요.
보통 이 세 가지 질문을 던지는 게 필요해요. 첫째, 이 모델에서 우리의 qubit들은
무엇을 나타낼 건가요? 둘째, 우리 문제가 연속적인가요? 양자 컴퓨터는 디지털이기 때문에
문제를 이산화하는 방법을 찾아야 해요. 셋째, 문제의 토폴로지가 하드웨어의 토폴로지와
일치하나요? 맞다면 좋은 거예요. 하지만 그렇지 않다면 작동하게 만들기 위한 몇 가지 트릭이 필요할 수 있어요. 자, 이
첫 번째 질문을 다뤄봐요. 특히 새로운 개념으로서 매핑을 이해하는 데 있어 모든 어려움의 핵심이라고 생각하는 거예요.
qubit은 무엇을 나타낼 수 있을까요?
qubit은 많은 것을 나타내는 데 사용될 수 있어요. 제 생각에 가장 첫 번째이자 가장 간단한 건 그래프의 노드예요. 그래프는
연결성을 나타내는 데 사용되고 다양한 유형의 수학적 문제들에서 쓰여요. 그리고 노드는 네트워크 내의 점이나
개체를 나타내는 기본 요소예요. 전체 네트워크가 무엇을 나타내느냐에 따라 도시, 사람, 또는
격자의 강자성체가 될 수도 있어요. qubit은 또한 보손과 페르미온을 나타내는 데도 사용될 수 있어요. 여기서 주의할 점은
단일 qubit이 보손 하나나 페르미온 하나와 정확히 같지 않다는 거예요. 조금
더 복잡하고 곧 자세히 설명할게요. 하지만 일반적으로 어떤 통계를 따르는 스핀 체인은
qubit 아키텍처로 쉽게 변환될 수 있는 것들이에요.
이제 조금 더 복잡한 예시들로 들어가고 있어요. 이런 모델들의 경우 단일 qubit의 관점에서 얘기하는 건 더 이상
의미가 없어요.
대신, 물리적인 무언가를 구성하기 위해 qubit들의 그룹이 필요해요. 예를 들어,
heavy hexagonal 토폴로지 위에 표현된 qubit 그룹을 아미노산이나
폴리머 사슬의 기하학적 위치를 나타내는 데 사용할 수 있어요. 또 다른 예시는 고에너지 물리학 모델에서 하드론 산란의
시뮬레이션인데, 이건 hadronic 파동 패킷의 시간 진화를 시뮬레이션해서 할 수 있어요. 이 경우,
qubit 레지스터를 양자 장의 다른 상태들을 인코딩하는 데 사용할 수 있어요. 그 장의 진공 상태나
이 진공 위에서 전파하는 파동 패킷 같은 것들이요.
또한 문제를 양자 컴퓨터에 매핑하는 데는 별개의 단계들이 있다는 점도 언급하고 싶어요. 하나는 상태를 qubit과 circuit으로 매핑하는 거고
두 번째는 비용 함수나 양자 관측량과 연산자의 기댓값을
매핑하는 거예요. 구체적인 예시들에서 이것들이 어떻게 처리되는지 볼 거예요. 하지만
지금까지 우리 앞에 놓인 과제에 대해 충분히 추상적으로 이야기했어요.
이제 이 예시들을 자세히 들여다봐요.
첫 번째 예시부터 시작해요. 제 생각에 가장 쉬운 매핑 문제 중 하나는 우리가 이미
어느 정도 자세히 다뤘던 max cut 예시예요. 그 문제에서 매핑은 qubit 하나가